oh
papa was a rolling stone we got one of
those right here welcome back to cbs
morning mornings more than 50 years ago
at just 21 years old what were you doing
at 21. john winner co-founded a small
music publication in san francisco it
was called rolling stone you heard of it
yeah you have the magazine quickly
became one of the most respected and
widely read in america it is published
more than look at these covers published
more than fifteen hundred issues
covering and shaping music politics and
pop culture now with his new memoir it's
called like a rolling stone where'd you
get that title yawn winner he's sharing
a very intimate look at his own life in
its many ups and downs he writes about
his private and family life and close
relationships and friendships with the
likes of the beatles mick jagger bob
dylan yoko ono bette midler just to name
a few jan wenner joins us now here at
the table i'm so glad to see you listen
the book is close to 600 pages what were
you going to say you read so much like a
movie that i thought we were going to
throw to a clip of it already like have
they already started casting this thing
i know that's so true because john i i
want to go back because you open the
book with that last day and you're
leaving the rolling stone offices and i
want to talk about your feelings there
but your first editor's letter you said
this we have something here for the
artists in the industry for every person
who believes in magic that can set you
free so take us back to yawn winter 21
because you were fearless you were quite
bold you were quite uh tough some people
say and a tad arrogant what was your
thinking back then that arrogant um you
were very confident
i fell in love with rock and roll music
at a point when i was in college i
couldn't play it but the
idea of it so suffused me i mean i felt
that thing which has the the with the
spoonful said the magic that can set you
free yeah and there was something about
that rhythm and that freedom and the joy
of it that i just had to be part of rock
and roll and so this is the way i was
going to do it i could write about it
yes didn't play it very well saying it a
lot but
uh that's what the magazine was devoted
towards bringing that message of freedom
and vitality and and and within that
human justice did you want to be
controversial because you had a lot of
controversial things in your publication
no are you thinking that i didn't set
out to be controversial i mean it just
happens
and you discover quickly that you know
well that's great if you're in the news
business that's what you want yeah um
and uh
it was a lot of the contraries are
really great journalism that brought us
along and got us our success by kind of
breaking story after story you know and
it was a good journalism yeah i mean
really fantastic i mean tom wolf was one
of the early writers
thompson yeah annie leibowitz came by as
a photographer i think she was an art
student she was an art student in 2021
yeah and then there's the the performers
themselves the the the singers the
songwriters they're also flocking to the
magazine they're writing letters of
complaint when they don't think the
reviews are adequate i mean were you
finding these people or were they
finding you a combination of both
people and
musicians and the musicians was shocked
to see this publication
that was covering rock and roll
seriously taking it you know absolutely
joyfully but taking it like an adult
genuine respectable art form that was
and when we came along was just teen
magazines you know covering music beat
ties of beans
or the trades which were kind of you
know irrelevant really uh so people saw
and wanted to be monitored and make it
succeed
want to help it get along want to be a
part of it and our early success is
based in great part on the beatles on
john lennon particularly wanting to send
his stuff in the rolling stone and
wanted to be in the periodical and it
was with john that we rose he wrote
helped us rise to success well you had
that very concrete
where they were both nude and they
didn't want to put it on the album cover
and i said we'll put it on the cover of
rolling stone then you sat down with
john and then he got upset with you
where you had a little bit of a falling
out a little that's a bit of falling out
i did when he was when i was 25 and he
was 28 i think it was right now we did
the interview where he talked for the
first time ever about what it was like
to be in the beatles inside the beatles
before they've been this kind of
pre-packaged the fab four stuff he let
loose and he let loose and it was
brilliant and that got a lot created a
lot of controversy yeah uh but i think
that over the years he just decided that
he shouldn't have he used to start
calling civilian remembers he'd call
lenin regrets yeah and anyway he
objected my publishing as a book i
wanted to publish the book and i think
it turns out that that
book that interview is a key piece of
history's appeals i mean a really
historic and how do you tow that line
between telling the truth telling your
truth the magazine's truth and also
balancing the relationship
good question yeah
very admittedly i'm really good friends
with a bunch of the people that we cover
as the pictures show i mean how many
boats and how many places
yeah fishing with mick and i think the
thing is
you have to understand two things one is
that these are people who are not making
faulty cars or putting out cigarettes or
they're not politicians these people are
doing good they're making music and art
they're generally genuinely happy you
know they're right they're making the
world a better place so they don't need
that kind of inspection that kind of
those rules that apply to public figures
the other other thing is that
in the end if it's if it's really nobody
ever
asked for me to change their record view
or another star or whatever that just
went without saying but in the end
you've got to go with
as a journalist the truth yeah you know
as a publisher i think that was the
fundamental value of rolling stone to
its readers
to me and to the artist
and the artist thought they had
something really special here i think
that should be protected and right and
integrity was one of those things can we
talk about gus winter your your son
2028 yeah who's now running 32 32 32.
who's now running things he he certainly
has that confidence and swagger that you
had you made it clear that you would
sort of like to hang on not hang on but
you would like to remain and do things
and you said gus listened impatiently
but respectfully what's it like when you
still want to be involved and your son
is like basically no dad i got this
you got it this gus handling was such
tlc and it was such an old bull in the
china shop and i so much wanted to be
still stuck in the closet giving advice
and
cuz eased me out with real gentleness i
mean really thoughtful and always just
to tease them that like it was going to
be like tommy boy in that movie you know
and
he was a champion he's more than ready
to take a great job
you talk about your health issues good
lord john what you've been through i
mean you're throwing a ball with your
son noah you said unasked to do so you
break your femur that leads you have a
heart attack spinal fusion spinal
fusions then back to the surface
i mean you had a lot of stuff and you're
you're close with bruce springsteen and
his wife patty ski alpha i love all the
bruce stories but you just mentioned to
bruce casual you know they say doctors
perform better if they're listening to
music in the operating room bruce and
patty show up at the hospital they have
a mixtape for to be played during your
six-hour surgery right wow do you
remember i know i thought that was so
cool do you remember any of the songs
that were on it yeah well i remember
first of all this is going to give me
good treatment from this doctor
really take care of me yes
um yes yeah the i remember this well
there was jackson brown on it and van
morrison my favorites a bunch of country
stuff this beautiful song and it's
called night shift by the commodores
which yeah yeah
his little it was about death i mean
that was jericho just the fact that he
took the time to do that for that it's
just a knockout john real quick best
concert you've ever been to
the best was the one i produced honestly
nope modestly called the rock of the roy
the uh rock and roll hall of fame 25th
anniversary concert at madison square
garden starring
bruce bono
mick jagger stevie wonder uh aretha
franklin oh uh oh man probably sells
nash paul simon and simon and garfunkel
wow i mean an incredible two nights of
four hours a night it was just magic
amazing i know those nights i know i
know you enjoyed going back in time uh
the spirit of the times that you were
able to capture people reading this book
will get that same feeling that rush of
happiness that giddiness it's there on
the page it is i know we gotta go you
say you're a 75 year old man but you
feel so young at heart i do too six kids
you've had two spouses one great spouse
both your spouses have been fantastic
shout out to matt now good weather sun
sparkles on the ocean the dog sleeps at
your feet life is pretty good for you
life is good you're on your own buster
brown yes
that's what your mom used to say thank
you fun read oh i'm reading thank you
john winner oh great the book is called
like a rolling stone it's on sale now
wherever you like to buy your book